In this lecture, we'll
see how analytics
can be used to predict the
outcomes of cases in the United
States Supreme Court.
This seems like a very
unconventional use
of analytics, but in 2002 a
group of political science
and law academics decided to
test if a model can do better
than a group of
experts at predicting
the decisions of
the Supreme Court.
In this case, a very
interpretable analytics method
was used, called classification
and regression trees.
The legal system of
the United States
operates at the
state level and at
the federal or
country-wide level.
The federal level is
necessary to deal with cases
beyond the scope of state law,
like disputes between states,
and violations of federal laws.
The federal court is
divided into three levels--
district courts, circuit
courts, and the Supreme Court.
Cases start at the
district courts,
where an initial decision
is made about the case.
The circuit courts hear appeals
from the district courts,
and can change the
decision that was made.
The Supreme Court
is the highest level
in the American legal system
and makes the final decision
on cases.
The Supreme Court
of the United States
consists of nine
judges, or justices,
who are appointed
by the President.
This image shows the nine
Supreme Court justices
from the time period
1994 through 2005.
This was the longest
period of time
with the same set of
justices in over 180 years.
The people appointed as Supreme
Court justices are usually
distinguished judges,
professors of law,
or state or federal atttorneys.
The Supreme Court of the
United States, or SCOTUS,
decides on the most difficult
and controversial cases
in the United States.
These cases often
involve an interpretation
of the Constitution, and have
significant social, political,
and economic consequences.
There have been many significant
and groundbreaking decisions
made by the Supreme Court.
These are a few notable
decisions that were made.
In 1942, the Supreme
Court decided
on the Wickard v. Filburn case.
This case recognized the power
of the federal government
to regulate economic activity.
Filburn was a farmer,
who was growing
wheat for on-farm consumption.
However, the US had established
limits on wheat production,
and Filburn was
exceeding those limits.
So even though the extra
wheat he was producing
was for his own use and he had
no intention of selling it,
he was forced to destroy it.
In 1973, the Supreme Court
decided on the Roe v. Wade
case, one of the most
well-known cases to this day.
They decided to legalize
abortion, and by doing this,
prompted a national debate
that continues today
about the legality of abortion.
In 2000, the Supreme
Court actually
decided the outcome of
the presidential election.
The race was so close
in the state of Florida,
that a recount of the
ballots was required.
But the Florida Secretary
of State certified
that President Bush was the
winner before the recount
could be completed.
The case then went
to the Supreme Court
where it was ruled that all
ballots needed to be recounted.
But since this could not be
done before the winner had
to be declared, President
Bush won the state of Florida,
and thus, the presidency.
A very recent case from
2012 dealt with the Patient
Protection and Affordable
Care Act, commonly
called ObamaCare, which
requires most Americans
to have health insurance.
The Supreme Court
upheld this requirement.
Since non-profits,
voters, and anybody
interested in
long-term planning can
benefit from knowing the
outcomes of the Supreme Court
cases before they
happen, legal academics
and political
scientists regularly
make predictions of
Supreme Court decisions
from detailed studies of the
cases and individual justices.
In 2002, Andrew
Martin, a professor
of political science at
Washington University in St.
Louis, decided to
instead predict
decisions using a statistical
model built from data.
Together with his
colleagues, he decided
to test the model against
a panel of experts.
They wanted to see if an
analytical model could
outperform the
expertise and intuition
of a large group of experts.
Martin used a method called
classification and regression
trees, or CART.
In this case, the
outcome is binary.
Will the Supreme Court affirm
the case or reject the case?
He could have used logistic
regression for this,
but logistic regression models
are not easily interpretable.
The model coefficients
in logistic regression
indicate the importance and
relative effect variables,
but do not give a
simple explanation
of how a decision is made.
In this lecture, we'll
discuss the method of CART,
and a related method
called random forests.
We will then see if these
methods can actually
outperform experts in predicting
the outcome of Supreme Court
cases.